- Here's what you do,
just pull your dick out,
spit in her hand, and put it on there.
So I was like, fuck yeah.
So I took her hand, I licked it,
and I put it right on there.
Hold on to that for awhile.
And I put it on there, and
she just jerked me off.
(upbeat techno music)
Welcome to this is not happening presents,
one crazy night.
So this is what we do.
Where a bunch of comedians,
tell stories about a similar subject.
So this is just one crazy night.
- [Announcer] Please
put your hand together
for your host, Ari Shaffir.
(crowd cheers)
When I started going on the road,
I started opening for
this guy named Joe Rogan.
He does the UFC commentary.
We're out once, it was so fun.
I'm used to shows that
were like 25 people,
and we went out, I remember
in West Palm Beach Florida,
to this amazing show, they
were great every night.
And on Saturday night,
I don't know if you guys have ever been to
West Palm Beach, that's where
white trash was invented.
(crows laughs)
Not a fun place, but at
the end of the night,
on a Saturday night,
he goes hey let's go out and celebrate,
let's go to the strip club.
And I was like, well I
don't have any money,
so I mean, if you wanna pay for that,
that's totally fine, but
that's the only way I'm going.
So he was like yeah, ill pay for it.
So we all went to this strip club,
called Cheetahs.
Here's the deal, horrible club.
Fat girls working the
pole like left and right.
There was a pregnant lady stripping.
Like, not even like a little pregnant,
like 8, 9, 10 months pregnant.
Where arms and legs were coming out.
So we're at this strip club,
it's pretty horrible, and it's just gross,
it's just full of white trashy groseness.
My friend and I see that somebody,
in the middle of the like showroom,
like right where you guys are sitting.
We saw a girl, one of the strippers,
sitting next to a guy, at a table,
and her arm was going
like this the whole time.
And we're like what's going on there?
And we kept looking until we realized,
oh that girl is giving
that guy a hand job,
right there at the table.
Just right there,
so we all just turned
and just stared at it.
Were we not gonna look at a hand job
that's happening right in front of us?
There's no way.
It was awesome to look at,
until the guy like looks
up and locks eyes with us.
And we're like, uh that's fucking weird.
Sorry about that.
That's a very personal moment,
I shouldn't be staring at you in the eye.
But we still really wanted to look.
And then we figured like oh,
this place is just full of mirrors.
We can just look at the mirror,
and then back at the guy.
We're like, yeah you
get your degenerate on.
It was fucking great.
It was a little grainier, but like,
it did the trick.
Anyway, the girl finishes,
she gets up, she starts to walk away.
And, uh, hold your ews til later, please.
And my friend, Tait
Fletcher, that I'm with,
he goes, I'm going to
the bathroom right quick.
And I go, you just went
to the bathroom like two minutes ago.
And he goes, yeah you know.
No I don't know, I don't know.
What does that mean?
And he goes, I'm going to get
a hand job from that girl.
I was like, do whatever you want bro,
it's your decision.
I'm not gonna judge you.
So Tait goes off with this girl,
well we found out later
it was her first day,
her first week, and nobody told her
she didn't have to give out hand jobs.
(crowd laughs)
So one dude convinced her,
you know, when's the hand job start?
I guess that just happened.
So Tait went off, it was
like a hazing process.
You know how sororities are.
Tait goes off with her,
comes back, about you know,
two, three minutes later.
And he goes, alright you're up.
What, no I'm not up.
What are you talking about?
Absolutely not.
And he goes dude, I already
gave her 20 dollars.
Now, here's what you
should know about Jews.
It is very difficult for us to just
let any money go to waste.
If there's twenty dollars,
if there's ever been a
kryptonite for our people,
that's what it is.
Letting twenty dollars
go to some stripper,
there's like no way, without earning it.
So I'm like, alright.
Well fine, I'll do it.
So like, what do you have to do?
Because I've never done this before.
I've never done anything like this before.
It was so foreign to me.
I'm like, so how do you make it happen?
Do you just go to them like,
uh one hand job please.
Do I take a number?
Like what the fuck's the process?
And so he goes, dude just take her,
like away to one of the
private rooms or something.
And just, I already gave her
the twenty bucks for you.
Just, here's what you do,
just pull your dick out,
spit on her hand,
and put it on there.
And then she'll do the,
if uhh you mean uhh-awesome,
yeah you're absolutely right.
But I've never done it
so I don't know if that's
gonna happen or not.
So alright let's go,
so we went to this private room.
Semi-private, it's like you know,
you have like a little half wall.
Like a urinal wall next
to you and another guy.
So this girl, like I sit
down and she's starts like,
you know, lap dancing me.
And I'm like I'm freaking,
I'm so worried about
actually pulling my dick out.
Because if she's not into it,
like if Tait was lying to me,
it's a really bad move.
You know what I mean.
There's no like halfway
on a dick pull out.
That's like, you did it, you did that.
So she's on top of me dancing,
and I'm so fucking worried.
I'm like alright, I gotta go for it.
So I just, I pulled my dick out.
I unzipped and pulled, and
she didn't freak out at all.
So I was like fuck yeah.
So I took her hand, and I licked it,
and I put it right on there.
Hold on to that for awhile.
Hold on to it.
And I put it on there,
and she just jerks me off.
It wasn't even like all
the way out of my pants.
It was like just to the edge.
She just jerked me off.
It was right at the the
end of the song too.
Cuz like the song started
like winding down.
And she was like, should I,
you want another dance?
But I knew that was the
end of the twenty bucks,
and I was so close, so I
just like pushed into her.
I was like, no we're good now.
We're good.
Like I came right as she was like.
And I was like I'm cool.
So then she went her way,
I went to my friends.
And they saw, like did
you get the hand job?
And I was like yeah.
And there like yeah,
oh yeah we can tell
because the fucking
wet spot in your pants.
Just a big wet spot,
wet spot of shame of
shame just right there.
And we looked around,
it's like oh there's wet
spots all over this place.
It was like a bunch of
people with wet spots.
It was like oh you met that girl too?
Oh cool.
It was almost like an
I gave blood sticker.
But it's like, I gave cum.
Just letting everybody
know that this happened.
Anyway, we left the place.
It was done, let's go out.
We went and got burritos
at some shitty place.
And my friends asked me,
like what happened, how did it go?
And I told them.
You ever get a realization
that happens to you,
and you realize what the truth is,
and you're just overcome with shame,
or whatever it is.
I was telling them, like what'd you do?
I'm like I pulled my dick out,
I licked her hand, and I put it on there.
And my friend said, Tait,
at Tait Fletcher on twitter,
he said, no I didn't say lick her hand.
I said spit on it.
I was very clear.
And I was like I'm not an asshole,
I'm not gonna just spit, it's right there.
It's some sort of.
And then he's like dude,
what did she do right
before she did that for you?
I'm like she, oh fuck.
She just jerked off at
least two guys that we saw.
We were only there for like 12 minutes.
She never once like made an attempt to
go to the bathroom to wash her hands off.
It wasn't like, I gotta,
of fuck another hand job to give, alright.
She never tried, like maybe she was
using cum as a cleanser for her hands.
To clean off some Chinese
food she had earlier.
Yeah I pretty much gave
my friend a blow job.
That's pretty much what happened.
Not even the fun part of the blow job,
where you get to give joy to someone.
Just the horrible part, where
you get cum in your mouth.
That's it, thank you very much everybody.
Hi everybody, I hope
you enjoyed the story.
If you did click like down there.
So that more people know you liked it.
And don't forget to subscribe
so that you'll get the next story.
As soon as it comes out.